my last girlfriend easy isn't even the
only girl that I dated long distance I
dated another girl long distance but she
dumped me she broke up with me and and
when it happened it kind of came out of
nowhere but now when I look back on it I
think there were some warning signs
coming
you said Ron's got that 20/20 vision I
was I was blinded by the light uh uh I
should have seen that comment you
because well like here's what happened
two weeks before she dumped me
we had a pregnancy scare right and it
was my very first pregnancy scare it was
at least her third because she has two
children she has two kids and when she
when she dumped me when she found out
she wasn't pregnant with my kid she got
so excited that it kind of hurt my
feelings a little bit does that make
sense I don't get me wrong I was also
excited but she was like way more
excited like I was normal excited she
was black Church excited
like as soon as she found out the room
was full of doves a choir came out of
nowhere
outcast performed outcasts at two songs
a pinata of her womb descended from the
ceiling she smashed it open nothing fell
out of it and then she dumped me right
she dumped me and I thought it was a
good relationship and she ended it
anyway right and maybe it was maybe it
was a good relationship and maybe
sometimes even good relationships have
to come to an end that's just part of
being human right hmm that's just part
of being human punches that's just true
words right there sometimes even the
most beautiful things have to come to an
end somewhere someone out there is still
driving one of those pimp my ride car's
right think about the reality of that
[Applause]
ten years ago there was nothing on the
planet cooler than a pimped ride that
was the coolest thing just whipping
around town on a tan jell-o Celica right
depicting your friend up for lunch
friend gets in the car like where we
going for lunch right here panini press
right in the middle in the middle but
now it's ten years later and that same
guy is driving that same car to pick up
that same friend from the airport and
that car is busted now friend is
standing there with his luggage like
where should I put my suitcase I don't
know why don't you put it in the fish
tank that hasn't had a fish in it for a
decade exhibit needs a new show where he
finds those rides that he pimped and
fixes what he did to them
just exhibit rolling up on people like
yo what's up dog
I know 10 years ago we put 8 GameCubes
in a bowling alley in your Scion but
honestly we thought you would have a new
car by now but since you don't
me and the boys at West Coast Customs
pooled our money together and put down a
down payment on a Mitsubishi go off for
your ass
sorry about everything
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography